تستمر في اسرائيل التظاهرات ضد مضي حكومه
نتنياهو في تعديلات ترمي للحد من صلاحيات
القضاء كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما المرحله التي توشك معركه
التعديلات القضائيه على الدخول فيها مع
تصاعد الاحتجاجات ضدها وكيف ستتعامل حكومه
نتنياهو مع الاحتمالات التي يقترب منها
ملف التعديلات القضائيه وما الانعكاسات
المستقبليه التي ستطول صوره اسرائيل
وسياسات حكومه نتنياهو
نحن لا نتحدث عن اصلاحات قضائيه في هذه
المرحله بل نتحدث عن تغيير للنظام في
اسرائيل نحن نرى الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والائتلاف الحكوميه الحاكم في اسرائيل في
محاوله تغيريه للنظام من نوع من
الديمقراطيه الى ديكتاتوريه في اسرائيل
نحن نتحدث منذ عام 2018 يعني على مدار خمس
سنوات على الاقل هنالك حاله من الفوضى
السياسيه بل عدم الاستقرار السياسي في
داخل المشهد الاسرائيلي ككل الوحدات في
الاحتياط في جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي ترفض
الانضمام للخدمه العسكريه خدمه
للدكتاتوريه قيد المنشا على سبيل المثال
رئاسه الاركان في الجيش الاسرائيلي
والخدمات والاجهزه الامنيه لديها معضله هل
تتبع الحكومه او المحكمه العليا اعت انها
سوف تختار بان تتبع قرارات المحكمه العليا
ولو ان بعض الوحدات على المستوى المتدني
قد تتبع اوامر الحكومه لكن المطاف هنالك
الكثير من السيناريوهات في العصر الحديث
عن يعني تازم الحاله الى حاله امنيه خطيره
الان ما هو موقف هذا الجيش هذا الحصانه
الاولى التي اسرائيل راهينتها ورهينه
الثانيه الاغتيالات السياسيه في الذاكره
الجماعيه الاسرائيليه اغتيالها بان كان هو
احد اهم الامور التي تقف عندها الخطوط
الحمراء
[موسيقى]
اذا ما استمرت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بعدم اخذ المظاهرات بعين الاعتبار قد يؤدي
بها الى ازمه حقيقيه ليس فقط بين المجتمع
المدني والحكومه بل نتحدث عن ازمه دستوريه
هي
رهينه بياض الصهيونيه الدينيه يعني ليس
فقط
الصهيونيه الدينيه يحاول تقييد ويحاول
مسايره هذا اليمين المتطرف بان ياخذ
ويسيطر على زمام الحكم في داخل المشهد
الاسرائيلي وربما هذا هو الانقلاب في
نهايه المطاف الخيارات امامنا نتنياهو هي
صعبه للغايه اذا ما اختار ان يمضي قدما
وينتهي من المرحله الاولى من التشريع الذي
يؤدي الى الحاق ضرر جسيم
بالقضاء كما يحاول يقوم بها ان نتنياهو
تسائل الشك في مساله مدى اهتمامه وتركه
التزامه بالديمقراطيه الكامله وعندما تحدث
رئيس بايدن مع نتنياهو قال له انما يقوم
به نتنياهو يحاول القيام به في مجال
القضاء غير حكيم وامر لا ترحب به الولايات
المتحده في حال تم الغاء التشريعات يتعين
على نتن ياهو ان يغير الائتلاف الحكومي
وحزب لابيد وحزب غاند سياتي الى الائتلاف
لكي
يستبدل
الدينيين المتطرفين هم يودون الوصول الى
تفوق اليهود في المنظومه القانونيه
القضائيه وان يكون ذلك جزء لا يتجزا من
دوله اسرائيل هذا هو الهدف من الحركه
الدينيه
[موسيقى]
نحن نرى المراحل الاولى من حرب اهليه حيث
اننا لمده اشهر شاهدنا حربا اهليه بارده
والان تصبح اسخن لا اعرف اين سوف ينتهي
المطاف بنا
الفلسطينيون الاسرائيليون لا ياخذون طرفا
في هذه الحرب الاهليه اسرائيل الكلاسيكيه
التي ندركها التي عايشت على مدار 75 عام
هي نتاج وليده هذا اليسار في هذه المرحله
اليمين يحاول ان يسيطر عليها على مدى
سنوات الفيصل ما بين اليمين واليسار
الاسرائيلي كان القضيه الفلسطينيه في
العقدين الاخيرين
وهمش هذا الفيصل وهمش القضيه الفلسطينيه
تماما ولم تعد هي الفيصل ما بين اليمين
واليسار الاسرائيلي ونجم عنها فيصل جديد
الا وهو الصهيونيه
بحتاقد النواشنتين البيت الابيض
يرون ما يحصل في اسرائيل عنه امر مؤسف جدا
من ناحيه التاريخيه لطالما دعمت اسرائيل
ليس لانه دوله يهوديه بل لانها دوله
ديمقراطيه يبدو لي بحسب ما ارى ان الرئيس
الامريكي
سوف يرسل رساله عبر الرئيس الاسرائيلي الى
رئيس مجلس الوزراء نتنياهو وهذه الرساله
سوف تكون الرساله الامريكيه اعتقد انه على
مستوى العسكري وعلى المستوى الاستخبارات
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل سيواصلان
التعاون كما فعلوا منذ عقود ولكن على
المستوى السياسي اعتقد انك بالتاكيد نظره
او فكره بان نتنياهو
يتمنى ويشجع العوده الى البيت الابيض